House Tyrell trace our descent to Garth
greenhand
the legendary first king of the reach
who made the land bloom but so too does
every noble house around us it seems
dear ancestor Garth
planted as many flowers as he plucked a
king should have more consideration for
his line don't you think for over a
thousand years the green hands sons and
grandsons ruled the reach at house
gardener the offshoots of his daughter's
grew into fast and powerful houses in
their own right except for house Tyrell
we chose instead to serve our gardener
cousins faithfully as stewards to manage
their stronghold of Highgarden and the
daily affairs of the reach our words are
growing strong and under our stewardship
the reach did just that as did we until
a blundering King almost cost us
everything Aegon Targaryen had landed in
Westeros King Mern allied us with the
rock to repel the upstarts army one can
only marvel that King Mern did not
reconsider when he saw the living
dragons against him
perhaps he should have sought counsel
from his trusted stewards before he set
out then again perhaps he did at the
field of fire agon and let us not forget
his sisters burnt the combined armies of
the reach and Rock King Mern paid for
his misjudgment with his life and that
of his ancient family in a day the reach
had lost its king its ruling house and
most of its army thankfully for everyone
my ancestor Harlan Tyrell had better
sense until the maesters sorted out the
Intel among Mearns cousins Harlan the
Stuart was acting Lord of Highgarden to
ensure peace and life in the reach he
would yield the castle to Aegon the
other castles and families would then
follow as they had since the dawn age
Aegon had a continent to conquer and the
Fertile reach was too valuable to raise
he accepted Harlan's proposal and
welcomed our lands into his kingdom to
show his gratitude Aegon entitled Harlan
to Highgarden the castle his family had
served for a thousand years and made
house Tyrell his wardens of the South
choosing us over older greater families
in the reach our house thus owed
everything to the Targaryen 's so is it
any wonder we stay true to King Aerys
even during his madness and even after
Robert Baratheon rebelled some may
question my father for laying siege to
the Baratheon's home instead of marching
to aid Prince Rhaegar before Robert
could kill him and scatter the royal
army but let us not forget that we had
already dealt Robert his only defeat of
the war at Ashford if Lord Tywin
Lannister had not vanquished the Mad
King so suddenly our siege would have
destroyed Robert's home in his brothers
and won the war for Aerys but when the
Targaryen spell
House Tyrell again chose peace and
prosperity over war and devastation and
bent the knee to King Robert Baratheon
first of his name we returned to
Highgarden to manage the affairs of the
reach as we had for thousands of years
and will for a thousand more other Great
Houses take lions and wolves for their
sigils and draw their power from the
goal than their mountains or the cold of
their winters but mountains run dry
winter yields to spring and the Rose
blooms once more